[Musik]
männer gesucht für gewagte reise wenig
lohn bitterer kälte lange monate in
kompletter dunkelheit sichere rückkehr
ungewiss
vor mehr als 100 jahren suchten solcher
inserate todesmutige männer
es war das goldene zeitalter der polar
expeditionen der basler xavier märz
bewirbt sich dieser text wird für ihn
zur prophezeiung
es wird kalt dunkel und xavier märz
kehrt nie zurück
das ist das letzte bild von ihm
wahrscheinlich der mann ganz rechts
nur einer der drei männer wird
zurückkehren
[Musik]
märz wurde in der heimat schnell
vergessen obwohl er der erste schweizer
war der seinen fuß auf die antarktis
setzte
[Musik]
nicht immer eis sondern in den
graubündner bergen treffen wir den mann
der xavier märz dem vergessen entrissen
hat per zufall stößt just auf der mauer
auf das tagebuch des jungen abenteurers
und schreibt über ihn ein buch je länger
ich mich mit ihnen beschäftige desto
schwerer ist mir die ersatzlose kripo
der situation die abschlussquote gefalle
ich hätte gerne löst ab zuvor anime
derartige ideengeschichte bg dass ich
bin ich habe gleich ob i feel ziel
gestern die dir die mangelhaft die
yamaha eric was sie greifen so zeige
komplizierter das buch über claudia merz
erzählt auch die geschichte einer
expedition die hierzulande keine
schlagzeilen machte denn sie ging nicht
für die eroberung des südpols an den
start was die welt damals vor dem ersten
weltkrieg in bann hielt sondern märz war
mitglied einer wissenschaftlichen
expedition der australier die die küste
des kontinents erforschen wollte es
haben sich viele fotos erhalten
märz der ski ausbildner märz der
bergsteiger und ein spezialist
märz der hundeführer
und merz der patriot die aurora das
expeditionsschiff dass merz im sommer
1911 in london besteigt märz ist kein
seemann er ist doktor der jurisprudenz
auf der überfahrt von london nach
australien muss er sich als matrose erst
beweisen juli 1911
ich habe london adieu gesagt und will an
verschiedenen orten der antarktis die
schweizer fahne hissen als in der themse
die dampfmaschine der aurora einsetzt
merkt man sofort dass 48 schlittenhund
entdeckt sind
die kommandos an bord sind kaum zu
verstehen fasst kollidieren wir mit
einem anderen schiff
es ist meine aufgabe mich während der
expedition um die hunde zu kümmern
gemeinsam mit einem engländer ergriff
nannys ein angenehmer zeitgenosse
oktober seitdem kap der guten hoffnung
scheint das mehr ewig weiter tun zu
wollen
in einem moment steht die aurora hoch
auf dem kamm der welle dann scheint es
als jage sich direkt auf den meeresgrund
nur um sich gleich wieder gen himmel zu
richten
seekrank wurde ich zum glück noch nicht
darauf habe ich im stillen einen stolz
die engländer müssen nicht glauben dass
wir schweizer keine seeleute sein können
auf see braucht es ebenso wie in den
bergen schwindelfreie leute nach den
hunden macht die überfahrt schwer zu
schaffen
sie werden von rieling zu reden
geschleudert und es ist zu feucht an
bord eines meint sie kriegen zu wenig zu
trinken
süßwasser ist knapp 10 der hunde sind
bereits von krankheit und den rauen
umständen an bord dahingerafft worden
sehr betrüblich
november 1911
der sturm hat nachgelassen
der kapitän hat uns aufgetragen die
aurora zu streichen das schiff soll bei
der ankunft in hof einen tadellosen
eindruck machen
vor uns liegt das abenteuer wen gott
seine rechte gunst erweisen den schickt
er in die weite welt
[Musik]
er gehe an den südpol sagte jost auf der
maur jeweils wenn er sich in sein
kleines büro zurückzog um die geschichte
niederzuschreiben
doch nun will er mit eigenen augen sehen
wo die männer monate lang ausgeharrt
alle ort wurden ich mich jetzt der
proteine zu setzen
stelle
das scheint ja so dass wenn die große
hatte ja und dann einfach die hütter die
hüte ja ja das war in die was würde und
so beginnt diese reise vom antarktische
fantasierten warmen büro in chur in die
wirkliche antarktis
es ist die reise des tragischen helden
und seines biografen die etwas vereint
dieselbe route
sie führt von robert im süden
australiens wer die insel macquarie
island zum antarktischen kontinent das
ziel der reise ist kate dennison das
hauptquartier der damaligen expedition
in der sogenannten kammer wels bay
[Musik]
die bucht von herbert von hier aus ist
das schiff aurora im dezember 1911
ausgelaufen
und hier will auch jost auf der maur
sein schiff besteigen
nein das hier ist es nicht sondern dass
hier ein ehemaliges russisches
forschungsschiff dass nach der überfahrt
von wladiwostok gerade im hafen von
robert einfährt sich auf rechts beck als
england sowie so der leiter der
damaligen expedition war douglas mawson
seine dramatische über lebensgeschichte
kennt ihn herbert jedes kind mawson ist
hier ein nationalheld im hafen steht
dann auch ein exakter nachbau der hütte
in der die 18 abenteurer stürmen und der
kälte trotzten das original in der
antarktis ist im schnee und eis
konserviert geblieben
es ist das ziel von jost reisen jetzt
mir immer vorgestellt auftrumpfende plan
und der vorteile und gold sind auch
betriebe der wagen ist sehr gut
der abschied in london er mit denen
beide damen auf der rohrer das bild von
der mutter spielt für den metallica
dahinter hinter der wand muss im
wahrsten sinne schlafkoje sie also die
musische seite blühte steuer durch muss
am zug
das
das grammophon
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dezember 1911 die zeitungen berichten
täglich von unseren keeper wir sind 23
australier vier neuseeländer drei briten
und ich ein schweizer exot
immer wieder bekommen wer besuch von
einheimischen während wir die aurora
beladen und die expedition vorbereiten
kohle benzin petroleum reichlich
proviant und ausrüstung sogar lebende
hühner und 60 schafe während unser
leiter vorträge hält machen wir die
stadt unsicher
alle reißen sich darum uns zu tennis und
golf partien oder picknicks einzuladen
man trifft uns aber vor allem in der
elisabeth street bei erdbeeren mit sahne
noch nie im leben habe ich so viele
erdbeeren gegessen als die aurora
ausläuft herrscht strahlender
sonnenschein der pia der queens werft
ist schwarz vor menschen ist stolz dass
die erste australische expedition von
hier abwehrt
gerade noch rechtzeitig gebe ich meinen
letzten briefe vor der abfahrt auf
die akademik schock als die im hafen von
robert wartet hat keine lebenden lüner
und auch keine schafe an bord dafür
nimmt sie 40 touristen auf
[Musik]
der traum dieser menschen ist es einmal
im leben den fuß an den ort zu setzen an
denen die legendäre expedition mawson
ihr haupt lager aufgeschlagen hatte ob
wind und eis das zu lassen ist
allerdings alles andere als sicher
die akademiker kalski ist kein
eisbrecher aber sie kann durch bis zu
einem meter dickes eis pflügen
ihre besatzung ist russisch 20 männer
und frauen
jost auf der mauer als schweizer ist der
exot unter den vornehmlich australischen
passagieren der exot wie damals klavier
märz
ja
ja ich habe schon mal eigentlich eine
hoch geachtet aber weil eine cabrio
buche
[Musik]
nach den strapazen des jetlags folgt die
erste miserabel noch und auf sie
die hälfte
schlechter schlaf einmal berichtet
rüstungskäufe in drei portionen
zum glück weiß just auf der mauer noch
nicht dass das im laufe der reise nicht
mehr besser wird
[Musik]
auch das erste frühstück will gut
ausbalanciert sein
[Musik]
hast du gut geschlafen teilweise es ist
schwierig für mich auch aber nicht
seekrank
das beste ist nicht darüber sprechen
nicht dran denken dann passiert das
nicht
[Musik]
doch das ist erst der anfang 3000
kilometer liegen zwischen dem
australischen und dem antarktischen
kontinent 3000 kilometer durch die
stürmischsten gewässer der welt
expeditionsleiter howard wheeldon trifft
sich jeden morgen mit dem kapitän auf
kommende stürme sind dabei das alles
beherrschende thema kann ich die wind
grafiken vier morgen sehen igor kiselev
ist seit 18 jahren kapitän auf der
akademie schock als gilt die beiden
haben bereits mehrere antarktis
expeditionen zusammen unternommen dass
es besser als wir dachten wind von mehr
als 60 knoten ist ein starker sturm aber
das ist kein problem für dieses schiff
es ist einfach unangenehm für die crew
und die passagiere
man schläft und ist schlecht er ist der
beste
ich habe es ist schwierig so zu filmen
jost auf der maur kämpft derweil nicht
nur mit dem gleichgewicht sondern wie
sein landsmann xavier märz auch mit dem
englisch doch mit antenne hat er
jemanden gefunden der mit deutsch
vertraut ist die ehemalige lehrerin
fährt schon zum vierten mal ins eis
kannst du begreifen dass in der schweiz
märz ein unbekannter mensch ist
nein ich habe diese reise schon vor zwei
jahren gemacht
gerade weil sie auf den spuren einer
australischen expedition unterwegs war
es war so fantastisch dass ich es
wiederholen wollte wir erreichten die
hütten damals nicht es gab zu viel eis
und ich hoffe dass wir es dieses mal
schaffen
aber auch wenn es nicht klappt es lohnt
sich
es ist einfach aufregend zu versuchen an
diesen wunderbaren ort zu gelangen
drei tage ist die show kalski auf
offener see 1500 kilometer endlich kommt
wieder land in sicht
die passagiere sind aufgeregt sie hoffen
dass der wellengang eine landung mit den
schlauchbooten erlauben wird macquarie
island ist für sie heute wie damals für
die expedition mawson der einzige stopp
auf dem weg zum eisigen kontinent
[Musik]
mailand ist nur 30 kilometer lang und 5
breiten massen an see elefanten viele
vögel und pinguine
all das ist meinem auge fremd am ufer
verrotten zerschellte schiffe hier auf
halbem weg zwischen australien und
antarktis werden wir eine telegrafen
station betreiben
[Musik]
zum ersten mal wird die drahtlose
kommunikation aus dem ewigen eis mit der
heimat möglich sein
für den transport auf eine kleine anhöhe
errichten wir eine primitive seilbahn
bei windstille verständigen sich die
telegraph ist ein pfeifen mit dem morse
alphabet an weihnachten springt der wind
plötzlich um die aurora treibt hin und
her
das meer ist zu unruhig zum angriff wir
müssen umgehend aufbrechen fünf mann
bleiben bei der telegrafen anlage zurück
sie werden von uns erst wieder aus der
antarktis hören
[Musik]
kontrollieren sie bitte ihre
schwimmwesten sie müssen eng anliegen
das glück fährt mit am frühen morgen ist
es fast windstill eine seltenheit hier
[Musik]
irgendwie pinguine immer wir uns gesetzt
vom schicksal
die comco sieht die bank ist ins tor
ja ja ja ja ja
macquarie island ist weltnaturerbe aber
bis vor wenigen jahren war hier vieles
kaputt
denn matt moore island war das reich der
robbe und pinguin jäger mit den jägern
kamen auch kaninchen und ratten die die
natürliche vegetation zerstörten nach
aufwendigen renaturierungsarbeiten sieht
die insel heute wieder aus wie vor 100
jahren
die öfen in denen das tier öl gewonnen
wurde stehen noch als mahnmal der
schlachterei
im sommer leben hier heute 25 forscher
und eine handvoll unbezwingbarer während
des winters morgen wird es wind geben
die ankunft des geologen rasmussen war
der beginn von australiens
naturforschung an diesem ort war das der
telegrafen himmel von mawson ja darauf
hat müssen die maßen schleppen lassen
funktioniert hat die funkverbindung in
die antarktis allerdings nie richtig
von hanna john hunter jenny und
schnellen ist großvater mehr als hier
bin ist natürlich und vertritt die
stiftung die sich um den erhalt der
historischen hütten kümmert auf dem
schiff ist er der mann für die
expedition geschichte es gab drei ärzte
zwei soldaten ingenieure segler ein
meteorologe ein fotograf ein ehemaliger
weiblicher spion
darüber reden wir später ein bauzeichner
ein nationaler champion
märz natürlich weiß jost meriva märz als
sonst jemand just ist der biograf von
merz lassen wollte kluge fitte junge
männer mit moral wichtig war nicht was
sie wussten sondern was sie konnten
greg hat die hütten auch noch nicht
gesehen
das ist ein 20 jahre altes foto
wir haben den schlüssel wir sind bereit
und so fühlt sich denn mancher auf
dieser reise selber wie ein entdecker
sie sind genau dasselbe wie manson und
seine männer wie ihr das beschreibt die
wetter und sie bedingungen am tag als er
aus hoben ausläuft es waren die gleichen
bedingungen wie für uns tatsächlich dort
zu stehen mit allem was wir über ihn
gehört und gelesen haben dort zu stehen
wo er stand das wird sehr stark sein
irgendwie wäre ja januar 1912
der antarktischen kontinent liegt
versteckt hinter unendlich viel eis mama
und die meinen denken wollen nicht sie
haben aber keine ahnung wie schön es
hier trotz der kälte ist
gegen mittag gerechnet festland
expeditionsleiter mordend auf die bucht
kommen weltbild das ufer bietet uns eine
felsige fläche hier entsteht unsere
basisstation kate dennison
der wind weht kräftig wir können nur
arbeiten wenn er ruht dann aber ohne
unterlass
zehn tage lang löschen wir die ladung
über 2000 kisten werkzeug schlägt
instrumente schier kohlebriketts und
bauteile für die hütten
am nächsten morgen liegt die rohre haben
für mehr wie ein jahr bleibt jetzt die
welt sind weiter ferne
an jeder bekam richtige abschieds
gefühle
[Musik]
passt bitte auf haltet euch gut am
geländer fest wenn ihr euch auf dem
schiff bewegt wir werden etwas stärker
schwanken in den nächsten stunden
[Musik]
die wütenden 50er so nennt man die
breitengrade in dieser weltgegend sie
geben sich alle ehre
es sind starke westwinde die die show
kalski samt ihren passagieren ins
trudeln bringen
zur freude der einen
[Musik]
und zum leidwesen der anderen das ist
die stunde der board ärztin leslie sie
fühlt sich ein klein wenig miserabel
heute morgen verlobt wie geht's etwas
unter dem durchschnitt
du kannst zum frühstück und verschwindet
wieder oder ich machte den abgang bevor
ich dort ankam
wie war es denn in den letzten tagen
eigentlich ziemlich gut aber noch
macquarie island ging es wieder los
ich entschied dass ich mich nicht allzu
gut fühle hast du etwas genommen
ich probierte etwas mit stimulierenden
mitteln aber dann kannst du mit deiner
magischen pille
ich hoffe sie ist magisch zitronen in
lahti
manchmal hilft immer schau dass du
genügend trinkt es hängt nicht davon ab
wie stark oder wie fit man ist oder
irgend sowas
manchmal trifft es die mannschaft sogar
schlimmste ich war schon auf einem
schiff der standen noch zwei leute
aufrecht ich und ein passagier und alle
anderen waren krank es kann alles
passieren
chancen er war die ganze zeit sehkraft
jeder dachte er sei ein unnützer
expeditionsleiter auch die besten
entdecker wurden seekrank ich komme
später
ich liebe die nach sich jetzt auf der
reis hälfte ist um
das erschöpft sein natürlich
das genüge lebt das gemälde
ja
mai 1912 mit dem ersten blick aus meiner
karriere ich das barometer daneben das
basler warten und mein thermometer
mollige 45 grad celsius herrschen in
unserer hütte draußen nur wind
schneetreiben und eisige kälte minus 30
grad
bei schlechter witterung verliert man
draußen leicht die orientierung hodgman
hat der orkan 20 meter vor der hütte zu
boden geworfen
kriechend fand er nach zwei stunden den
weg zurück wir hatten in der
zwischenzeit vergeblich nach ihm gesucht
[Musik]
unter unserer hütte lagern wir rechtlich
pinguin fleisch mit curry ist es
durchaus genießbar
wir verteilen orden für zweifelhafte
leistungen am herd
erster august schweizer nationalfeiertag
jungen jack und schweizer fahne hängen
heute nebeneinander
ich koche meine beliebten pinguin eier
und erzähle von daheim die sympathie
gefühle meiner kameraden sind so warm
dass ich einen ersten august erlebe wie
noch nie weiter entfernt vom vaterland
war nie ein schweizer
doch tiefer konnte keine empfinden wie
lieb in die heimat ist jenny und naomi
sind enkelinnen des damaligen expedition
arztes
ich war zu krank um tagebuch zu
schreiben
wir haben den see bau von john hunter
nicht geerbt das bin ich
das ist schon hunter sie zeigen jost das
tagebuch ihres großvaters dass sie
kürzlich veröffentlicht haben wir halt
warst du da 4
meine älteste erinnerung ist dass er
einen großen ausgestopften pinguin oben
auf dem büchergestell sitzen hatte als
kind liebte ich den warum seid ihr jetzt
darf dieser reise wir wollten das schon
immer machen unsere eltern waren 1998
auf dieser reise auf dem gleichen schiff
sie hatten glück und konnten in der
carmen wolf b landen und die hütte
besuchen
hoffentlich können wir auch so ein foto
machen john hunter schreibt über märz
sehr gute dinge wir müssen es suchen
er ist ein feiner stärker kern ist
zweifellos der zäheste von uns er wird
sicher eine der schlitten expeditionen
anführen er unten ist betreuen die hunde
und er legt hand an wo immer er kann
seine hilfe beim häuten ist unbezahlbar
wenn er nach australien kommt bereiten
wir ihm eine
gute zeit denn er ist ein guter kamerad
hat merz nachkommen in der schweiz
es gibt keine familie
es waren fünf kinder aber es war eine
unglückliche familie der vater der vater
war sehr streng drakonisch keiner hatte
kindern
der moment der schlechten nachricht wie
muss das gewesen sein für unseren
anführer allein zurück zu kommen
wir können nur vermuten was geschehen
ist entweder sind sie verhungert oder in
eine spalte gefallen
ama xavi armanis zwei besseren männer
gab es nicht und jetzt sind sie tot
und dieses verfluchte land ich kann
nichts mehr sagen ich war in meinem
ganzen leben nie so traurig ein guter
schreiber
das ist okay denkt ihr wir werden die
hütten sehen wo wir hoffen es ich möchte
das hier sehen ein sehr besonderer ort
[Musik]
es ist der 23 dezember zwei tage nach
der sonnenwende erreicht das schiff den
66 breitengrad den polarkreis
ganz dunkel wird es jetzt nicht mehr
[Musik]
alle bereit für den polarkreis
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nur wenige menschen haben den polarkreis
mit dem schiff überquert das bringt auch
eine verantwortung mit sich
denjenigen entdeckern gegenüber die vor
uns waren und die diese verantwortung
ernst genommen haben
sie traten für den schutz dieses landes
und der tiere ein
dieses besiedeln so dass auch zukünftige
generationen freude daran haben ich
möchte dass heute jeder ein gelöbnis
abgelegt und das zeichen des pinguins
entdeckt hiermit gelobe ich
mit dem empfang des pinguin zeichens
jedem klar zu machen
auch denjenigen die nicht hören wollen
wie wichtig die antarktis und ihr tier
leben ist kommt jetzt nach vorne und
empfand das zeichen des pinkls
mario ist es einfach
er sagt nur
in grenzen
das eis wird nun zusehends dichter
der kapitän weicht nicht mehr von der
brücke
er muss einen weg finden durch den ice
gürtel der vor der küste liegt die
größte gefahr strömungen die das eis so
treiben dass sie das schiff einschließen
und festsetzen
[Musik]
kroth form
möglichen punkten erhielt
das ereignis findet
müssen sich die für alle sehr spannend
[Musik]
das meer vor der küste ist offen die
chancen stehen gut
[Musik]
kate dennison die ersehnte küsste sie
liegt zum greifen nah
doch dann machen die rasenden folgende
die vom innern des kontinents herunter
fähigen dem unternehmen ein ende
130 stundenkilometer das zu viel für
eine landung
die akademiker kalski flüchtet sich
wieder ins offene gewässer am nächsten
tag kommt sie zurück
es ist sechs uhr morgens strahlender
sonnenschein und weihnachten
[Musik]
familie muss verzichten und das gerade
auf die backe ich hoffe dass sie das
pathetisch meine einzige angehörige
wohnen
der jako erwiesen
dieser tag verspricht nur gutes und
wieder scheint das ziel in greifbarer
nähe
aber boden auf der brücke ist die
stimmung eine andere
kapitän igor gefällt die sache nicht und
dann winkte ab
[Musik]
das reicht im moment fast bis zur küste
es bewegt sich auf uns zu und dieses
gebiet wird wahrscheinlich
eingeschlossen werden
während wir gestern in der carmen we're
still geblieben
dann setzen wir jetzt in der fall das
ist nicht die situation auf die wir
scharf sind
wir kehren jetzt um und fahren durchs
eis zurück
[Musik]
die expedition mawson suchte damals
tagelang nach einem ort wo man sicheres
festland unter die füße bekam nicht dass
man sich irrtümlicherweise auf einer
riesigen ei schule niederließ aber als
ungemütlicher hätte sich der ort der
landung nicht entdecken können
woher wissen sie das ist ein dies
freihafen naturhafen doch haben relativ
einfach land das noch eher die
wahnsinnige sturm mit haltung
sie sind in dem moment ob das
entschieden hätten
windgeschwindigkeiten bis 300 km/h der
bloß als weg mit vorgebracht sagte das
ist der wichtigste ort auf der welt
überhaupt
september 1912 mein freund - und ich
schaffe es das erste mal die
schlittenhunde einzuspannen
die fahrt läuft die recht flott bis wir
uns überschlagen
wir trainieren nun täglich und bringen
den hunden befehle bei abends sind wir
rechtschaffen müde
mein liebling unter den hunden ist
unbestritten basis er ist aufgeweckt und
mir sehr vertraut
wichtig der lead für ihn denn basilisk
sondern sakrament breiten penguins die
ersten schlitten expeditionen
unternehmen wir ohne die hunde hold me
nes und ich bilden eine gruppe die
schweizer fahne wird am schlitten mast
gehisst
zum ersten mal flattert das weiße kreuz
im roten feld in den regionen des
antarktischen kontinents
dann werden wir ohne vorzeichen von
einem kran überfallen
zwei stunden haben wir in schutz des
schlittens aus bevor wir es schaffen das
zelt zu errichten
in der nacht nimmt der wind noch mal zu
der kran löst sogar die flamme im
inneren des täters
wir rechnen mit allem auch mit dem hände
tatsächlich aber lässt der sturm in den
morgenstunden nach erleichtert aber mit
erfrierungen machen wir uns auf den weg
zurück zur basisstation
jo
der wunsch der passagiere ist zwar noch
nicht in erfüllung gegangen
aber weihnachten findet trotzdem statt
auf der show kalski lässt man sich die
stimmung nicht kaputt machen
wurde hinzu jetzt noch mehr kunden
[Musik]
kostenlos sein
dirigiert wurde ordentlich kriegsopfer
[Applaus]
ja ja
wer zu nierenproblemen was eigentlich so
ähnlich aber er hat sich 18 44 fühle
mich akzeptiert in der gesellschaft muss
sehr geduldig mit mir
ja
fünf tage cruz die show kalski wie vor
einem mauseloch auf dem bildschirm
entsteht buchstäblich das bild einer
odyssee in der ostantarktis aber durch
winde und temperaturschwankungen können
sich die eisverhältnisse schnell ändern
denn passagieren bleibt nichts anderes
als zu warten und zu hoffen
[Musik]
mehr zu den themen
november 1912 - und ich sprechen mit
drei schlitten und 17 runden auf
500 kilometer wollen wir gen osten
vorstoßen und die wichtigsten
topografischen merkmale kartografie die
fahrt geht in richtig neues
unerforschtes land das noch nie ein
menschliches auge sah
dezember die reise ist beschwerlich eine
gletscherspalte folgte anderen jede
einzelne verlangt große vorsicht unter
uns kraft ist wenn die schneemassen der
gewölbe brechen ein teil von denise
ladung geht verloren
beinahe das ganze hundefutter ist weg
wir müssen immer wieder hunde schlachten
und ziehen die anderen tiere verfüttern
als wir über eine feine flache strecke
wandern kehre ich mich zu den kameraden
um das ninis weg sein ganzes gespann
verschwunden
eine gletscherspalte hat ihn
verschlungen beruf nach ihm aber nicht
nur totenstille hilflos stehen wir am
grab meines besten freundes in der
ganzen expedition
wir kehren um
fast alles essen teile des zeltes pickel
und schaufeln an die spalte mit minis
verschluckt die hunde sind schwach einer
nach dem anderen verendet die
verbliebenen zugtiere und auch wir
stellen unseren hunger an ihnen selbst
an meinem geliebten basilisk das fleisch
schmeckt muffig und ist zäh
weihnachtsmorgen börsen rechnet noch mit
258 kilometer die hälfte der strecke ist
geschafft
[Musik]
januar 1913 neuer licht unglaublich
schlecht himmel bewölkt deshalb kam er
nicht weit dass hundefleisch scheint mir
nicht ganz zu bekommen
denn gestern war ich etwas flau
[Musik]
gesagt wir mehr zeit kühles mehr als
gebieten die karten und und er muss die
umbringe
er wusste schlacht das ist eine unter
herzlichem verloren ist das ist sie noch
dem expeditionsleiter und ich glaube die
mentale erschöpfung sportler sehr gut
ist und alle berge führt bis märz
letztlich zum tod
[Musik]
die zeit läuft ab der schock als sie
bleibt noch ein letzter versuch die
küste der antarktis zu erreichen
[Musik]
wechselspannung baut sich auf
wie geht es dir dabei total aufgekratzt
das leben kann nicht besser werden
[Musik]
ein
wir sind runtergefahren soweit wir
konnten wir müssen mit den bedingungen
klarkommen
hier vorfinden wir können nicht in
dieses pack als vorstoßen es ist zu
dicht
[Musik]
du kannst die natur nicht schneiden
ja also schon wirklich schön jetzt und
sind jetzt im rat bei 40 kilometer von
cap technischen weg aber wir sind einmal
500 meter unterwegs und haben müssen
früchte
dialekt seitdem leer bleibt
aber wie
zuerst kommt die sicherheit
alle passagiere und die crew müssen
zurück nach hause und in dieser gegend
wenn wir im eis stecken bleiben wer
hilft es gibt kein anderes schiff
[Musik]
enttäuschen in ehren aber irgendwie
müssen die lebensgeister ja auch wieder
belebt werden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
naja
[Musik]
carlsen überlebt vielleicht auch dank
dem tod von xavier märz denn nun hat er
mir zu essen
kriechend erreichte einen monat später
die basis der züge zu spät er verpasst
die aurora die zurückgekommen war und
gewartet hatte um wenige stunden
morgen muss noch einmal auf kate
dennison überwintern
zurück in australien aber erfährt er
heldenhafte verehrung
er reist nach basel und übergibt märz
eltern tagebuch und fotos doch merz
gerät in vergessenheit
es gibt der mertz-gletscher
unternehmensgrenzen zwei diese gletscher
die erinnere da hat die beiden ja
immerhin
in der antarktis lässt sich nicht
erzwingen
und beschleunigen lässt sich hier auch
nichts
nochmal vergehen zehn tage bis die show
kalski wieder festland erreicht
noch mal zehn tage die immer wieder
beglücken aber auch immer wieder er
dauert werden müssen
eine reise geht zu ende grandios und
strapaziös die ohne das ziel zu
erreichen wären unerwarteten sinn
trotzdem findet
was so schön ist
ich dass ich erfahren habe dass ihre
australische gesellschaft der welt es
gerecht ist und dass ich mit dem märz in
dem sinn im ersten abschnitt waren die
fünf kilo ab
das sind ungefähr der kg war gestern
während schreiber vom wurde ich immer
mitglieder hat mit dem märz und um den
gasthof urin und dazu erklommen zu
erkennen ist das buch fertig sich
letztlich wieder los
[Musik]
[Applaus]